i want to ask you about another great
competitor michael jordan
um you guys were amazing competitors
back in the day
and recently we found this clip of the
two of you on a japanese
game show playing each other yes i want
to show this right now and you tell me
if
what you recall about this epic
competition between the two of you on a
japanese game show back in the day let's
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
get there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
first of all do you remember that
competition
i i remember it when you showed me the
highlight
that has to be 30 years old yeah
that's how long ago it was yeah but i
didn't remember it
until you said that in our debate we
were in japan
obviously on a nike deal but you know
that's why he's the goat man he beat me
but i totally forgot about that
you know what i love about that clip is
you can see
you're not taking it that seriously
michael's taking it very seriously
which might have been one of the keys to
his success he's not screwing around
well to say he's so tightly wound is an
understatement hey
hey that guy would he'd kill somebody to
win
yeah that's why he's the goat that's
what separated in my opinion him and
kobe bryant
like lebron magic tim duncan
bird those guys they wanted to win right
but michael and colbert are the only two
guys i know like they'd kill you to win
a game
right uh they had zero chill them two
guys
yeah that great documentary about jordan
that came out a couple of months ago
and they have this footage of him before
a game
pitching pennies to see who can get
closer to the wall
and he's as intense about that to get
the nine pennies or quarters away from
whoever he's playing
security guards he's as intense about
that as he is about
the playoff game he's about to go into
yeah he
uh you know for better or worse he's
he wants to win no matter what yeah
uh and like i said sometimes that's what
better works but he always wants to win
and that's
that's why i think he's the goat in my
opinion